Мінськ, лютий 2015.
За столом переговорів "нормандської четвірки" небагато оптимізму.
Тижні запеклих боїв на Донбасі змусили Україну,
Німеччину, Францію та Росію ухвалити мінські угоди.
Головна мета була - встановити тривале перемир'я на Донбасі,
що мало стати початком політичного вирішення конфлікту.
Однак, по суті, стрілянина відтоді не припинялася ні на день.
Лінія фронту залишилася майже, де й була, а бої тривають і донині.
Українські війська та проросійські сепаратисти
звинувачують одне одного в порушенні перемир'я.
Спостерігачі ОБСЄ продовжують моніторити порушення припинення вогню,
але обстріли це не зупиняє.
Тож, політично конфлікт залишився там, де він був
і три з половиною роки тому.
У Києві чоловіки в уніформі вже давно стали звичним явищем.
Найбільше їх можна зустріти на центральному вокзалі міста.
Багато з них повертаються на фронт.
Як ці люди бачать шанси на мир?
Чи вважають вони, що миротворці ООН можуть поліпшити ситуацію?
Весь час якісь зустрічі відбуваються, де просто
підтверджується вже те, що є, і нічого не зрушується з місця.
Все, що відбується в Європі, це ніколи не допомагає.
Поки ми самі в себе в країні не розберемося,
там ніхто нічого не вирішить.
Я сама з Донецька, людина, яка бачила ситуацію зсередини.
Коли все це починалося, здавалося, що мине час,
і люди одне одного почують і це закінчиться.
Зараз чим далі, тим віра слабша.
І дивлячись на все це, дуже великі сумніви, що
взагалі це закінчиться найближчим часом.
Звільнити свої території. Бо це війна.
Я думаю, що дипломатія не вирішить питань сама по собі.
Коли ці солдати дістануться своїх позицій уздовж
лінії розмежування на Донбасі, часто лише кілька
сотень метрів відділятиме їх від проросійських сепаратистів.
Створення озброєної миротворчої місії ООН дало б
сподівання, що сторонам буде важче порушувати перемир'я.
Але перш ніж це станеться, Київ і Москва повинні
узгодити масштаби та функції місії ООН.
Поки ж Росія заявляє, що підтримає лише невеликий контингент ООН,
розміщений на лінії розмежування.
Натомість Україна та її західні союзники хочуть
більш розширеної місії ООН, яка моніторила б і сепаратистські території.
У Києві мало оптимізму, що нинішні переговори в Берліні
можуть щось змінити, адже й попередні зустрічі мало що дали.
І поки залишатиметься такий статус-кво,
українські солдати і далі їхатимуть на лінію фронту.